google has announced that it's going to
be pulling the plug on developing first
party games for its streaming platform
stadia that's one year and 10 months
since it originally revealed the service
to the world
what happened to the original vision for
google stadia games and entertainment
and how did it change so quickly the
story's still ongoing so make sure to
subscribe for the latest
rumors swirled for years that google was
looking to get into the gaming space
hell even niantic creator of pokemon go
was a google offshoot
but nothing else ever materialized until
february 2018
when a report from the information
revealed that google was working on a
streaming service with the code name
yeti
yeti seemed to go on ice sorry for a few
months
until october 2018 when google released
a blog post
detailing the upcoming project stream it
was a closed
technical test in partnership with
ubisoft where users could stream
assassin's creed odyssey to chrome
browsers
those who were selected were able to
play the game for free until january
15th the following year as long as you
had an internet connection that could
hit 25 megabits per second
you could play the game at 1080p 60
frames per second
the tech test started on october 5th and
by all accounts
people were pretty impressed with it in
march 2019
google held a keynote at the game
developers conference in san francisco
where ceo sundar pichai took to the
stage to reveal that the company had
been experimenting with game
streaming tech for the past two years
and presented stadia to the world
welcome to stadia we are so excited by
this
phil harrison who you might remember
from the launch of the ps3 or the launch
of the xbox one
came on stage to give the full pitch and
what a pitch it was regardless of your
feelings around cloud gaming the initial
demonstration of a player going
seamlessly from desktop
to laptop to phone to tablet to tv
was super impressive best of all there
were no big downloads and no expensive
hardware
removing barriers to entry for players
was a key feature of stadia it had other
neat features too like a built-in google
assistant to help you get tips
the ability to play with your favorite
creators using crowdplay
and sharestate which would let you share
challenges with your friends
its integration with youtube offered an
easy way to quickly launch games
as well as ways to upload your gameplay
google promised that at launch
games would be playable at 4k 60 frames
per second
with hdr and surround sound it teased 8k
for the future
but we also know the widespread adoption
of 8k is inevitable
for developers there was a whole other
layer of intrigue
stadia was a platform that could solve
development problems by utilizing
google's vast cloud
and networking infrastructure developers
could create games in the cloud and
google promised that a single stadia
instance
offered more teraflops than ps4 pro and
xbox one x combined
a perfect showcase to show the power of
stadia was doom eternal
and while initially skeptical about the
tech id software confirmed the doom
maternal would run
at 4k 60 frames per second on stadia
google teased a multiplayer experience
that was reliable and free of cheaters
and hackers
all running on google's cloud it
discussed the potential for machine
learning and development and promised
cross-platform multiplayer
and even saves harrison then introduced
jade raymond
formerly of ubisoft and ea who had
joined google as the head of stadia
games and entertainment
the first party studio dedicated to
developing titles
exclusively for the platform to going
down the bold path
learning what is working best
and sharing key tools and tech so that
we can take games to the next level
together the way i see it there has
never been a more exciting time to be a
developer
and stadia will be a driving force
defining the future
of games and entertainment
thank you watching this back now is
genuinely pretty heartbreaking
on the gdc show floor both assassins
creed odyssey and doom 2016 were
playable
it wasn't the ideal test bed for the
tech but most press
agreed that the games looked and ran
great for the most part
but others noticed that doom had input
lag when using a mouse and keyboard
and i noticed immediately that you know
my mouse wasn't tracking 100 perfectly
with
uh with the aiming reticle like it was
laggy
cutting ahead of the other e3 press
conferences google held a stadia connect
with pricing game reveals and its launch
info on june 6
2019 for the most part it was a pretty
okay conference
it revealed baldur's gate 3 and stadia
showed off the list of developers it had
on board
including ubisoft ea 2k and rockstar
it showed off one stadia exclusive from
tequila works called guilt
gamers were promised 4k gameplay if they
had internet speeds of 35 megabits per
second
and 720p 60 frames per second if they
had
megabits per second it showed off the
controller and detailed the stadia pro
subscription service
which would give you a free game every
month discounts
and let you reserve your stadia name all
for ten dollars a month there was also a
service called stadia base which allowed
you to just buy
the games you wanted without a
subscription but they'd be kept at 1080p
60 frames per second but there were
certainly cracks in the presentation
you had to own a pixel device to play
stadia on your phone at launch
to even play stadia in 2019 you had to
sign
up for stadia pro stadia bass wouldn't
be coming until 2020.
google discussed the founder's edition
at length three months of pro for you
and a friend a controller and a
chromecast
ultra none of which you really needed if
you had a decent internet connection
chrome browser and a keyboard and mouse
and so the rumblings about the
practicality of stadia began
how much bandwidth would streaming 4k
take in countries like the us where data
caps are more common
was it feasible to use an eye-watering
article from pc gamer at the time
estimated that stadia would use one
terabyte of data
in 65 hours people joked about the
google graveyard
a depressing website where you can check
just how long google keeps its products
around for
others questioned why they would need to
add yet another subscription on top of
services like game pass
ps plus and ps now all of which arguably
offered better benefits
and way more games than stadia did
seemingly to address these criticisms
google held its second stadia connect
live stream at gamescom 2019 and pushed
the titles that would be coming to the
platform like cyberpunk 2077
watchdogs legion doom eternal elder
scrolls online and mortal kombat 11.
in october 2019 a month before launch
stadia games and entertainment opened up
its first
studio in montreal on the blog post
celebrating the opening
jade raymond wrote that the team would
produce exclusive
original content across a diverse
portfolio of games
in all your favorite genres founders
editions sold out so google announced
the stadia premiere edition
that came with a chromecast ultra a
white controller three months of stadia
pro
and destiny 2 all for the same price but
with the caveat that it would arrive
after the founders editions at launch in
november 2019
stadia had 22 games including metro
exodus
destiny 2 final fantasy xv and red dead
redemption 2.
reviews were mixed digital foundry
discovered that games were rendered at
sub 4k
and then upscaled for 4k gameplay you'd
be looking at streaming up to 20
gigabytes
of data per hour or just under 5
gigabytes for 720p
if your internet dipped you'd be looking
at frame skips and input lag
some founders editions arrived late as
noted by kotaku
multiple features were missing or just
not quite right
the share button would upload your clips
to the stadia app but you couldn't
download them from there
stream connect wouldn't launch for
another month and crowdplay wouldn't
even go into beta for another year
stateshare eventually stumbled out of
the gate in january 2021 with the launch
of hitman 3
it's still not widely usable in other
games while available on pixel phones
and chrome browsers
stadia like xcloud and geforce was
missing on one key platform
ios this was due to apple's app store
rules which stated that each game on the
service
needed to be individually submitted for
review apple eventually overturned this
policy and stadia became available in
december 2020
but you still had to access the service
through a web browser
in december 2019 google announced the
acquisition of typhoon studios
an independent studio co-founded by alex
hutchinson and reed schneider who
between them had worked on titles such
as assassin's creed
splinter cell and arkham knight speaking
to games industry.biz jade raymond said
there are always pros and cons to
acquisitions and i think when you find
the right culture and a really good fit
like typhoon is
it's a no-brainer but we take this very
seriously
we want to build for the long term a
whole strategy
is a long term one to make the right
decisions
in march 2020 a year after stadiu's
reveal
stadia games and entertainment opened a
second studio in playa vista la
helmed by shannon studstill the former
head of sony santa monica
google also started to offer free stadia
pro trials for chromecast ultra users
with the world descending into lockdown
in april google offered stadia pro for
free to new players
and paused billing for existing owners
for two months
to try and help entertain people at home
in june
google knocked 30 off the price of the
premier bundle
but dropped the three months of
freestadia pro throughout the rest of
the year
google would continue to run promotions
including giving free premier additions
to youtube premium subscribers
as well as those who bought cyberpunk on
the platform cyberpunk
despite varying in performance on most
other platforms
ran pretty well on stadium by the end of
2020 over 120 games were available
and several features including family
sharing and messaging had been added
which brings us to february 2021 and the
unexpected blog post from phil harrison
revealing that stadia games and
entertainment would be shutting down
and that the future of stadia would be
dedicated to its use as a platform
citing the exponentially increasing
costs of game development for the
decision
most of the rest of his blog post
discusses shopping the streaming
technology out to partners
but assured gamers that stadia games and
stadia pro
would still be around it's not the first
time this has happened
nvidia did the same things with g-force
and gaikai became ps now
as astutely pointed out by sean
hollister from the verge
harrison was on guy kai's advisory board
and jack beza
head of stadia business development was
head of ps now
so it's a strategy they're both familiar
with jade raymond left google the same
day
and the studios in montreal and la
shuttered with 150 developers losing
their jobs
harrison said they were working on
finding them new roles according to a
report from steven totillo at kotaku
any game that had a release date beyond
2021 had been cancelled unlike xbox or
playstation we have no idea how many
stadia subscribers there are
because google has never released any
figures the verge referred to cyberpunk
on stadia as the platform's make or
break moment
and it's easy to see why the biggest
game of the year had intense technical
issues on every platform
except stadia by offering a free
chromecast to everyone who purchased on
stadia
google was getting in front of more eyes
than ever but it seems like even
cyberpunk wasn't enough to move the
needle so as of 2021 does stadia still
exist
yes it does did it deliver on what it
promised in some regards it did
but many of its most exciting features
didn't come to fruition in a meaningful
way
and the accessibility it touted came
with numerous caveats
but perhaps stadia's biggest failure was
in the promises it made to game
developers
it courted 150 people to come work for
google and build games for stadia
and shut it all down before they could
even release anything this has been a
pretty depressing video to make because
the promise of stadia was so strong for
developers
for the most part the streaming tech
works and is being improved upon
all the time if stadia's new plan is to
be this platform to deliver games
straight to the players
but never to deliver those astonishing
games that could be made in the cloud
is that going to be enough to pull
people away from competing services
we'll see in the meantime we'll always
have the latest so make sure to
subscribe
to keep up with stadia i'm on twitter
lucy james games
i'll see you next time